we make way for the two-time emmy winner
crazy
it's so special you know it's such an
honor you know to be uh acknowledged for
something that you're really proud of
yeah um it means it means the world to
me and also like i'm so happy for so
many of our you know more behind the
scenes folks getting so much
acknowledgement cinematography and
editing and it's it's really really
special they deserve it so much they put
so much into this show you know that was
real cute but what you gonna do tonight
where are you going not much i'm gonna
do a little wardrobe change you know i'm
gonna do it you know do a little
two-step and then head on home because
i have work i gotta get back to work so
um i'm just gonna
take it easy you know i'm gonna have an
easy night okay you didn't shout out tom
was that night no no no no he's part of
my loved ones
there you go okay
how is 26 so far what did we do for 26.
26 i just i was just chilling yeah i was
chilling with loved ones with loved ones
and it was really you know it was really
special i just you know i just
i think it's uh time moves so fast
sometimes you just gotta like chill and
for my birthday this year i just was
like i'm just gonna chill like i'm not
gonna do a thing because i always am
doing a thing so you are a thing so it's
all good
at the moment and all of that we're so
proud of you yes congratulations
incredibly proud of you you go have a
great time tonight make that phone call
and go have it all right
with your loved ones going with your
loved ones
[Music]
you